all around the West the people are
recognizing that the problem is not just
the Democrats the Liberals though
everywhere in other than one country
other than in Hungary which is a little
advanced in terms of the conservative
populist Uprising in every other country
in the West
people are realizing that the problem is
not just the liberal party which is the
dominant political party
throughout the whole civilization and
the problem is not just the conservative
political party which is the junior
partner in the liberal project but that
maybe the problem is the whole system
maybe this whole system that we called a
uniparty here in America
or the liberal establishment or whatever
that the
semblance of political opposition the
semblance of the representation of
diverse voices that in fact
castigates a large part if not the
majority of the people as deplorable
irredeemable not worth hearing they
should just go off and die somewhere let
small town America die let these tell
these people to learn to code tell them
to shut up they're insurrectionists they
need to be put in prison they need to be
banned on social media
the people are recognizing that system
might be the problem which is why
a man that nobody had heard of until
three days ago Oliver Anthony just went
viral and now has the number one song in
America top of the charts in the country
the song is called the rich man north of
Richmond this song is such a phenomenon
we have we have to play at least a good
chunk of it on the show because
what's most interesting about this
phenomenon is not the song everybody's
saying oh this is the greatest song in
recent memory and this guy's a musical
genius and
hmm
the story is
is more politically interesting than
just that take it away
I've been selling my soul
working hard
[Music]
for both pains so I can sit out here and
waste my life away drag back home and
drown my troubles away it's a damn shame
what the world's gotten to for people
like me people like you wish I could
just wake up and not be true but it is
all it is living in the new world so
[Music]
these rich men north of Richmond Lord
knows it all tomorrow
so the first thing that strikes me this
guy is a genuine musical Talent his
voice is is
captivating
he reminds me of Levon Helm
who is the drummer in the bands you know
bold and Nazareth was feeling about he's
got this this way of wailing while he
sings that is
sounds raw it sounds authentic it's
a little dangerous it's not this is not
a classically trained singer obviously
was really good and his pitch is good
and he's playing a dobro guitar and the
whole thing just where he even looks a
little bit like Levon Helm he's got that
red beard and he's he's singing a song
about how he's selling his soul he feels
like he's losing his soul and he's
working for basically no pay and he's
drinking his troubles away and
the other thing that's that's raw about
this song is that
don't I'm not knocking the guy at all I
think this is a wonderful story and it's
a good song and but the the lyrics could
be tuned up you know he's rhyming away
with a way he's rhyming rich rich men
and Rich mend which is not those don't
actually rhyme the the lyrics are a
little bit confused here because is this
a is this a neo-confederate Anthem as
the Liberals are calling it Richmond is
the capital of the Confederacy so is
that what he's talking about those damn
Northerners coming in here and bringing
their reconstruction or something he's
wailing about this 200 years later 150
years later no I don't think so I think
he's probably referring to Washington DC
as the rich man north of Richmond and
they want to have total control
so they want to have total control but
is the problem that he's
that he is not making his money is the
problem that he is being forced to sell
his soul or being encouraged to sell his
soul is it is it a a substance question
the substantive nature of the political
order or is it a procedural aspect just
that these men want Total Control but we
don't want them to have control we're
not saying how people should live but we
are saying that those guys north of
Richmond shouldn't do it it's it's a
little bit confused so I don't think
that what is making the song go viral is
necessarily the lyrical content of it
you'll see why in just a second keep
going
do
and you know but I know that you do
cause your dollar ain't and it's time
[Music]
put a pause there this is
lyrically what's interesting to me too
is
you hear some real populist complaints
I'm selling I'm selling my soul
I'm not this is this is not the sort of
thing that Mitt Romney would complain
about there's another sort of thing John
McCain would complain about oh yeah this
new liberal economy is making us sell
our souls no and the we're not making
enough money
okay that's a populist complaint and
inflation is really bad the dollar ain't
worth that's a populist complaint
and it's taxed to no end
that
high taxes is not exactly a populist
complaint that's more of a an
establishment Paul Ryan Mitt Romney John
McCain kind of complaint and the fact is
virtually all the taxes in America are
paid by the rich anyway so it's it is
the rich men in Richmond well maybe not
them because they're corrupt government
apparatics in Washington D.C but it is
the wealthy generally who are paying
virtually all of the taxes in America so
that that's a little bit of a just
standard GOP complaint you know and
but the rest is populist and the whole
the whole vibe of the song is
this calling out literally calling out
from the woods in the middle of nowhere
right now go to hallow.com it is clear
that the libs are giving up their morals
in any Common Sense there's no better
time to build a daily habit of prayer
and meditation building a habit of
prayer can help you cultivate an
attitude of gratitude focusing on what
you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the United
States it's helped many maintain a daily
prayer routine and it can help you too
download the app for free at hallow.com
Knowles you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress along the way not
sure where to start check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in a year available
on the Hello app for brief daily
readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and
even some world-class athletes with
hallow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using Halo to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
also you have an obligation to your God
to pray regularly don't forget that
helps you but you have an obligation
okay so make sure you go check it out
right now hello go to hello.com Knowles
get an exclusive three months free
that's three months absolutely free at
hallow.com Knowles keep going
I wish politicians look out for minors
and not just minors on an island
somewhere or once we've got folks in the
street ain't got nothing to eat and the
whole Beast milking welfare put a pause
there so this is probably intentional to
to
be a contradiction or to maybe to seem
like a paradox but I don't think it is a
paradox I think it's just a
contradiction he's saying people in the
street don't have any food but but the
obese are milking welfare
people don't really go hungry in America
the the the knock on the American
political order is that the poor robs
and they're not just obese because
they're milking welfare you could
complain about welfare again that's not
totally a populist complaint that's a
little bit more of the Mitt Romney Paul
Ryan kind of stuff and people don't
really starve the problem is that the
poor in America are obese because
because of the culture problems because
we've we've sold our political Soul
because we don't have
really Community or political love
anymore because marriages have fallen
apart because we've got rampant drug
abuse and addiction because we've got
people who are despondent don't think
they have a future because their money's
not worth anything and they can't get
any good jobs and so it's
it's all kind of jumbled up
it's a it's a stew of lamenting about
the political order
keep going we got a little bit more of
this song God if you're five foot three
and you're 300 pounds taxes out not to
pay for your bags of fudge rounds
six feet in the ground cause all this
damn country does is keep on kicking
them down
lord it's a damn shame what the world
can it not be true but it is
all it is so this is this is where the
song really sings this is where the song
really takes off when you say when
you're five foot two and you're 300
pounds then welfare shouldn't be paying
for your box of fudge rounds and it's so
unfair because you got ordinary men who
are being responsible who are trying to
take care of themselves and they're
putting themselves six feet in the
ground because they're dying deaths of
Despair and it's a damn shame because no
one's looking out for people like me and
people like you
backbone of America no one's looking out
for us and it's a damn shame and I wish
it weren't this way but it is and that
that's where it really sings because
it's not this happy-go-lucky BS Beltway
establishment
astro turf conservative movement which
says everything's really great we've got
iPhones and cheap Chinese products we
need to stop complaining and recognize
what a special wonderful political order
this is you say no there are really
structural problems and maybe we do have
cheap crap from China and maybe in a GDP
has been ticking up but life expectancy
is going down so clearly something's
rotten here that's a a beautiful
complaint and he's saying and it's a
damn shame and it shouldn't be this way
but it is but it is
very different from the
bubble gum
appeal to the Southern Man movement
conservative kind of music this is not
your average country song
okay very different the political
analogy would be in 2016 you've got a
you've got a bunch of GOP candidates and
they all have the same roughly the same
kinds of complaints this immigration
illegal immigration is out of control
they never complain about legal
immigration which is the Lion's Share of
immigration they say this illegal
immigration is out of control and
there's some economic problems but look
we're still the greatest most prosperous
most wonderful country on Earth and it's
always we don't have any real problems
and everything here is great but we just
got to work around the edges a little
bit we got some problems to fix and then
Trump comes in he goes nah man this is
all going a Hell in a hand basket this
is completely screwed up we are we are
going to become one of those whole
countries pretty soon if we keep it up
and we're we've got chaos and
destruction in our streets and I'm going
to turn it around and make America great
again and what all the chattering
consultant Geniuses at the time said was
this is too dark
oh this is too dark
and divisive what was the title of
Trump's campaign book every other
campaign book is standing up for
standing
the courage to stand in freedom and
liberty and happiness and freedom and
courage in the future and the Sunshine
by Senator so-and-so running for some
office or whatever and then Trump's book
was crippled America
and this song is this this is the anthem
of crippled America
this is not your usual we're gonna put a
boot up your derriere because this is
America and we bleed red white and blue
all day I mean there's a place for those
songs this isn't those songs this isn't
even a country song this is a folk song
and for the people who are criticizing
this guy and saying well he just
shouldn't be political
he is coming out of a very long line of
American folk music
he shouldn't be political you know we
should just get back to the old days of
Folk Music like Woody Guthrie and Pete
Seeger and Bob Dylan and Bruce
Springsteen for that matter and Joni
Mitchell and all these all these people
Joan Baez
[Music]
they're always political songs and
they're always fairly
urgent contemporary political songs
the reason that this is so fascinating
that he took off is
he's the first one of them to be
conservative
Woody Guthrie communist Pete Seeger
communist Bob Dylan was a big lip he's
oddly kind of conservative and more so
over the years but he's considered a big
lip he's the people who really love Bob
Dylan tend to be hippies Joni Mitchell
Neil Young Joan Baez Arlo Guthrie all
that all the popular folk singers in
America actually Arlo Guthrie got a
little bit conservative too though he
kind of there he kind of went back to
being a liberal they're all big Libs
and the fact that you've now got a guy
playing it this could be a Woody Guthrie
song
but he's a conservative what that tells
you is
truly
for the first time in my life
conservatism is the popular
counterculture
liberalism is not only the political
establishment as it has been for a long
time but now everybody knows it
this is the the Woody Guthrie's of today
are that guy
and that means that the the political
playbook for conservatives
has got to change and finally
we can start uh we can stop telling
ourselves these fairy tales that we have
for 50 years oh we're the real cool kids
we're the we finally are the real cool
kids the evidence is this kind of a song
the fact that when conservative movies
do squeak through they do extremely well
the fact that when conservative
politicians do squeak through they tend
to do extremely well and they pose such
a threat to the liberal political order
that the liberal political order starts
changing all of the election rules right
before the elections starts rigging the
elections and starts trying to throw the
candidates into prison not just here in
America though they're obviously doing
that but around the entire West that is
an Insurgent culture that shows that the
people
after a long enough time have finally
woken up boy what a great clip now make
sure that you ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
see you next time